Ant-Man and the WASP Kwanza Mania is
almost in theaters and critics are
finally getting a chance to see the
finished product and they have thoughts
when Scott Lang joined the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in 2015 no one knew
what to expect after all Ant-Man was
subject to many creative changes behind
the scenes with the most notable being
the departure of original director Edgar
Wright however Antman on his sequel
Ant-Man and the WASP has proven to be
exciting additions to the MCU Cannon
giving fans moments of humorous respite
amid the more high-stakes Adventures of
the overarching franchise but this
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania live
up to expectations the third film in the
Ant-Man franchise marks the beginning of
Phase 5 of the MCU so the titular
Crusader has a lot of weight to carry on
his tiny shoulders the film sees Our
Heroes forced to try and navigate the
quantum realm which brings them into
contact with strange creatures and the
biggest threat to date Kang the
Conqueror
everything you call a life will end with
that in mind what do the critics have to
say about Marvel's latest Adventure the
general consensus among reviewers on
Rotten Tomatoes as that Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania is enjoyable for the
most part however as a movie it's very
flawed several reviewers pointed out
that the film was too focused on laying
the building blocks for Phase 5 which
comes at the expense of telling a fully
formed three-core story collider's Ross
Bonham wrote quantumania is a promising
but shaky start for Phase 5 of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it's just a
shame it comes at the sake of the little
guy meanwhile slash films Jeff Ewing
noted that the film gets Phase 5 off to
a promising start but it's undercooked
in the grand scheme of things he says
altogether the film is an engaging and
fun start for the real meat of the
Multiverse Saga it's also one that needs
more care and detail to flourish for
some critics like Jaime broadnax to
black girl nerds the three chord tries
to integrate several genre goes into his
narrative only to experience an identity
crisis as a result in her opinion
tonally this film is different from the
other films a bit uneven it feels like
Jeff lovedness's script wasn't sure what
genre this movie wanted to be that said
IGN movies Joshua Yale believes that
Marvel's latest Blockbuster has more
pros and cons writing Ant-Man and the
WASP quanta Mania has just enough heart
humor and excellent performances to make
up for his more in the developed aspects
cutting the Conqueror will be the big
bad of the MCU for the foreseeable
future with this story is set to ramp up
and conclude an Avengers the Kang
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
needless to say a Lotus riding on the
franchise's newest formidable Foe and he
has big shoes to fill considering that
Thanos once wiped out half of the
universe with a snap of his fingers the
good news though is that based on my
critics are saying that new body is off
to a flying start
writing for the guardian Ellen e Jones
praise majors performance and compared
the villain to one of the most morally
flawed characters in the Star Wars
franchise she said Mages brings the same
emotionally intense if Boy energy of
Adam Driver in the force awakens notice
how his eyes are often watery with
empathy for his victims even as he
throttles them elsewhere the Hollywood
reporters Frank Sheck praise Kang as a
highlight of the movie noting that he
brings a real sense of Gravitas to their
proceedings he writes while it's not
surprising that the actors imposing
physicality perfectly suits his iconic
villainous character he also invests his
performance with such an interestingly
quiet Stillness and ambivalence that
you're on edge every moment is on screen
USA today's Brian Truitt echoed these
sentiments stating that Kang's present
covers up some of the film's flaws
saying Mages thankfully rides the ship
every time he pops up with this
deliciously disconcerting presence
thank you
[Music]